muy buenos días Raúl Pues el mayor
desafío es entender que la guerra que se
está viviendo será larga pero que aún
así hay que ir ya preparando la paz
reiteró el compromiso de Francia con
Ucrania de continuar ayudando en
términos financieros en términos de
armamento y también humanitarios pero
explicó que hay que evitar sobre todo
que continúe habiendo una fractura de el
mundo fracturas por ejemplo que puedan
darse aquí en Europa por eso pidió al
cuerpo diplomático luchar aún más por la
soberanía europea en términos de energía
también de la clima y de alimentos y
evitar también digamos contrarrestar la
influencia que puedan tener países como
Turquía o Rusia aquí en el continente
europeo no solamente hablando de los
países que forman parte del bloque de
los 27 y también de países como china
sobre todo en la región Indo pacífica
uno de los puntos importantes
y seguir trabajando con países como Irán
para lograr finalmente tener ese tratado
nuclear con ese país Natalia le
preguntaron Cuáles son las expectativas
que tiene el presidente macron frente a
la postura de la diplomacia de su país
así después lo que ha pedido
Es simplemente que haya un refuerzo de
la influencia de Francia en el mundo
entero en términos digamos de salud
preparando las próximas futuras
pandemias pero también en cuanto al
clima en la protección digamos de la
biodiversidad y también en economía uno
de los puntos importantes en este punto
es que el presidente hizo énfasis en la
necesidad que esa digamos esa influencia
sea también a través de lo que se conoce
como el soft power que sea la educación
la cultura la gastronomía y también la
información ahí de hecho Emmanuel dijo
que uno de los aliados vitales digamos
para luchar contra Las falsas
informaciones Las falsas noticias en las
redes Pues será el audiovisual exterior
de Francia el cual forma parte nuestra
cadena las 24